yeah and uh yeah in terms of the
question will China to us out of the
economy's critical Chris Chris Chris I
don't think China can take too much
heavy responsibility at this time china
in past three decades even China has
already achieved very great
accomplishment in economic growth but
but mostly depends too heavy on low low
end or cheap labor intensive
business so I think channel also need
more time to enhance increase its
capability in a knowledge base industry
and also increases rd capability so but
anyhow the china is also a very huge
market consumer market so i think
definitely china will give the the World
more contribute in economy advice huge
consumer market but also China needs
some time to increase or enhance its
knowledge intensive capability is my
papa